hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are unboxing the sony RX zero
I've been talking about this camera for
quite a while Sony gave me a couple of
them to test out while I was in Hawaii
on vacation because we're in Hawaii
these weren't out yet but they are now
officially out mine finally came in the
mail and I'm so excited because this
thing is awesome my current favorite
point-and-shoot vlogging camera is the
Sony rx100 Mark v I've been using this
camera for the past couple of years the
rx0 is basically the rx100 mark 5 but
fun-sized mini sized GoPro size whatever
you want to call it it's tiny the real
difference between the semi rx100 mark 5
is that this one will not shoot in 4k it
will shoot in 4k if you record
externally but I feel like for most of
us we're not going to be bothering to do
that but the audio on this is great it
still has high frame rate most
importantly it's waterproof you guys may
have heard me making references to the
RX 0 and a bunch of my GoPro videos
because one of my biggest complaints
about GoPro is the audio is trash it is
absolutely terrible and I feel like that
would be something very simple for GoPro
to fix but I'm not sure why they don't
do it it upsets me but it's ok clearly
I'm over it
so let's try on boxing this rh0 I cannot
wait to show it to you guys I've been
waiting for this unboxing for so long
well that's it there's the whole
unboxing this looks like a little
something got our sony charger it just
charges through a micro USB we've got
our battery and unfortunately this
battery is not the same as the rx100
mark 5 which I was really hoping that it
would be it is much much slimmer in case
you're wondering and you wanted to get
an extra one it is the NP v j/1 it's a
little cute little guy got a wrist strap
which is very important because this
thing is so small if you hear out there
vlogging and using this you could easily
just misplace it well it's so awesome it
has a decent weight to it it feels a
little bit heavier than a GoPro but
there's so much packed into this little
bag here is our beautiful this is ice
lens here's the little door right here
which houses micro SD card has a little
microphone jack micro USB for charging
and transfer
and an HDMI port and here's your menu
system this is where you put your
battery in and this is very exciting
there's a tripod mount already built
into it pop this battery in make sure
you guys don't lose this little backside
because it does kind of pop up very
easily and another thing to note is the
SD card when you put it into here it
actually seems to fit both ways so you
may want to double check whenever you're
inserting a SD card that it's going in
the correct way there is a little
notation that'll show you how to put it
in the menu system is like a very very
micro version of the rx100 and salsa
very familiar if you've used any of
Sony's interfaces before it was a little
confusing at first but once you master
it it's super easy and it's very
intuitive let's see if we can power this
thing up hopefully we have some battery
and yes we do like I said it is so small
like the menu system is just incredibly
tiny it's very very similar to what
you're used to on Sony 60 frames at 50
30 at 50 24 50 120 at 50 so it's kind of
crazy that this little guy can still do
120 frames a second and here's our high
frame rate settings you can shoot up to
960 frames a second which is pretty
insane coming from this tiny tiny little
camera well now that you've seen the
unboxing I'm sure you probably want to
see some test footage so let's go back
to Hawaii where I was hits of Kosh it's
probably like a month ago at this point
and check out some of my underwater
footage we went shark diving
[Music]
there's the shark-cage and we'll be in
there very very shortly I'm kind of
scared okay so are you happy now
things just got so crazy from the simple
maybe it wasn't
wait
enough to almost make me still
[Music]
flushing up like this
I met you
[Music]
like you guys so much for watching hope
you guys enjoyed this quick little
unboxing and some footage from the rx0
this thing is awesome I absolutely love
it and I think one of my favorite
features really is how small it is but
also the audio is incredible one of most
difficult things I feel like in a lot of
small action cameras is the audio sucks
and this audio is almost identical to
the rx100 which is amazing granted it
doesn't do 4k I'm still very very
impressed with this camera and this is
definitely something that I will carry
around with me quite frequently when I'm
vlogging I'll also put a link in the
description where you can get more
information about this camera right here
and I will see you guys in my next video
bye
[Music]